so the infinite game and the internet
mindset is not the absence of the finite
game it's the context within which the
finite game exists and so we overuse
sports analogies and war analogies in
business which as you pointed out very
often our finite nature definitely
sports most of the time a war and so I
go back to my metaphor a moment ago
which is we need to adjust our mindset
to understand what business actually is
which is it's a lifestyle so we can have
finite goals we can have arbitrary goals
set to arbitrary dates I want to lose X
amount of weight by X date and you work
really hard to metrics are really
important you know as tangibly driven
animals we need to be able to count
metrics it makes us feel like we're
making progress really really important
and so I'm doing all the right things
and I'm measuring myself and I hit my
goal on the date and the problem is I
have to keep doing it now every single
day for the rest of my life it doesn't
end business is the same even if we hit
our goals we have to keep going so what
the infinite game provides is what is
this all for this has there has to be
something bigger than just hitting these
dates conversely if we miss our goal you
know what happens nothing nothing
happens in fact if we've been building a
good business if we've been living a
healthy lifestyle we're way better off
now than we were when we started and if
we just keep on this path we'll hit our
goal in another month or two right and
so I think one of the things that the
infinite game provides and how we do how
we conduct business at the frontline is
not just is not just the finite metrics
it's not just did we hit the goal on the
date but rather how did we get there
what's the trend data did we get there
in an ethical way are we promoting
people who who are building a strong
company for the long term for the
infinite or are we only promoting people
who hit the arbitrary number in the
arbitrary date we only evaluate so too
often we evaluate someone's performance
but we don't evaluate what kind of
character they have and so many
businesses so many leaders and
businesses will know that there's a
toxic team member but their numbers are
so good so we just let them keep their
job
as opposed to sitting down with them
coaching them or eventually removing
them regardless of what their numbers
are at the end of the day though the
front line has to be more preoccupied
with the finite game right because there
are beginning middles and ends for them
so let's take an airline analogy we
absolutely want those gate agents
obsessed with the finite game we want a
beginning middle and end we want that
plane to leave on time and then they'll
repeat the process but we need them to
be aware of the infinite game we need
them to understand that this company
needs to survive beyond this flight in
other words they need to treat the
customers nicely because they want the
customers to want to come back as
opposed to just getting this flight off
off the line on the time and and then
and then be done with it and we hear
that all the time I'm just doing my job
right like this is what we have to do
and this is sort of where bureaucracy
seeps in because bureaucrats don't care
about the infinite game they're just
trying to follow what's in front of them
but as we make our way through the ranks
at the senior level and you touched upon
this we have to become more obsessed
with the infinite game we have to become
obsessed with understanding how all
these pieces of the puzzle contribute to
the long game and how sometimes we're
gonna have to make decisions that hurt
us in the short term because it's the
right thing to do for the long term and
that's really hard to do and when you
have senior leaders who are overly
obsessed with the finite game then they
just make short decisions that are good
for now that actually do long-term
damage but at the frontlines we need our
people to understand what the vision is
we want them to be involved we want them
to work on trusting teams we want them
to start learning leadership so as they
work their way through the ranks
they bring that infinite mindset with
them as they come
[Music]